welcome back to new rockstars moonlight
episode 3 took us to the courtroom of
the egyptian gods and gives us a great
example of why you should always hire a
lawyer like at all times a really good
lawyer that can catch a brick don't
represent yourself in court say
objection mark but you got to do
something man jeez this is rogue theory
the show where we pitched the wildest
theories for the nerdy titles that we
love my name is mt and going wrong with
me today is the only person i trust with
my power of attorney it's jessica
clemens what's going on juice
i don't win in fights i'm a horrible
debater and i don't really know the law
and i don't really know i break a lot of
rules i break a lot of rules
you gotta know the law to break the law
baby come on
steady act in the
law and someone who i would suspect
makes little stone figurines out of her
enemies it's whitney van lenningham
what's going on girl
oh
i do
oh i absolutely do and they're called
little guys and then you're little guys
you just line them up and you get mad at
them
and you get to use them as action
figures like oh hello greatest enemy
little guy hello other great ahead of me
time to go in the toilet it's like when
you're a child in therapy and you go to
like a child psychologist and they make
you pick out action figures from the
wall and then they're like act out why
your daddy doesn't love you and you're
like
um it would be like that but with just
my enemies
so it would just be my dad who doesn't
love me you know would be great honestly
it's the way to go it's the way to get
through therapy voodoo and finally
and finally someone who is certain to
win any rooftop knife fight is angelica
trey what's going on
oh yeah i don't know if i'll be licking
any knives though
that was a question what if they have
your favorite pastry on them what if you
cut into your favorite pastry and then
they had that what if there's butter on
it what if you're playing
i do like to lick straight butter off of
knives how did you know jess
i sensed it
looks like a buttercream i look like a
butter licker i know
[Laughter]
for real though butter is delicious oh
it is
not to get confused not to be confused
with margarine not to be like a
margarita don't eat margarine yeah
margarine wow are we an anti-margarine
podcast now is that is that are you
taking a stance it's for baking not for
eating off the spoon well guys what
about that trial we saw take place
inside that great pyramid because mark
wanted conju to summon the gods but it
doesn't seem like they had a great plan
for convincing the inead that arthur
herrera was up to no good so this leads
us to our first topic today
is the idiad corrupt because during that
debacle of a trial we see the idiots
summon arthur harrow and basically just
take everything he says as truth so why
do the gods trust this former avatar of
conscience so much and what should we
make of him conversing privately with
osiris's avatar while hathor's avatar
yatseel secretly helps mark if the gods
agree with harrow's quest to free ahmed
why don't they just release her like can
we trust any of these deities like are
they all just i'm doing some sketchy
[ __ ] what do you guys think
i think
i thought we were getting into a
riveting box competition
oh my bad
i just assumed we were all beatboxing
instead uh no i think
i think a little yes and no i agree and
disagree with like if they're corrupt so
i don't think the entire idiot is
corrupt i think that osiris is misguided
and i think that arthur harrow is the
the most persuasive man on the planet um
so essentially what i was thinking about
was that
he is a cult later and let me tell you i
love colts so
right here no this is just my notes so
so i think okay so we have let's let's
talk about what we
what we kind of already know emmett is
like
emmett's whole goal was like to destroy
it at the roots to eradicate evil at the
roots to get them before they're even
alive that's why he was like that means
you're killing a baby before you even
got like judged the baby and they're
like well we have to get rid of it
before it becomes evil and then consciou
is someone that need to let the evil
deed be done and then enact justice so
their missions are kind of the same
they're aligned with the same thing
except for emmett is like destructive
clearly hers is going to be killing a
lot of people and the indian doesn't
want anything to do with humanity
they're like we don't want to get into a
human's business that's not our game but
konshu and emmet do and amid did it too
far so they locked her up so khan shoes
along those same lines where they're
like it might be best to just lock this
man up he's going to move the stars
again we're going to get involved with
the humans business and we don't want to
do that these two people are definitely
people we don't want on this planet
right now so i think they're not i think
osiris as the leader isn't necessarily
like corrupt i think it's just like
getting rid of two bads and also the god
of the underworld and if amit is the
swallower of people that are unworthy
why wouldn't he be okay with amit being
released so she can swallow people and
send them to the underworld to osiris i
think putting osiris as the leader of
the union was a bad idea because that's
a slippery slope to a very evil way
an evil deed so i think
he could possibly be corrupted but not
not too much i think the idiot still has
a power over osiris as the leader to be
like don't do this
but i think he is okay with putting
konchu in a box because he's just
constantly over playing his powers and
just being reckless
i is that enough is that that's not
really rogue but more of
like that makes
a lot of sense because like you know at
the end of the day the council of gods
are there to
preserve order in some respect and so
like if conscious moving moons
he kind of has to be put away in like in
that respect and like you same with
ahmed like if ahmed was just doing
things on earth and just judging people
and like not doing good like and just
running amok
she she had to be put away as well so
like i understand yeah like yeah
they probably are not evil they're
it's hard because a piece of me wants to
believe that emmett and uh conscious are
working together i want to be like they
could potentially be working together
because they're they align completely
it's just that the way they're doing it
it's like the same thing with like
t'challa and uh eric killmonger it's
like
eric's not a villain it's just that he's
doing it in a bad way i have i believe
that emmett is like okay i understand
that you want to get rid of evil people
you would have stopped hitler before he
actually
or like killed everybody but also you
can't just judge a baby you can't judge
someone that hasn't done an evil deed
yet so that's why i'm like conscious and
her are on the same plane it's just
their ways of doing it are completely
different they could be working together
they could be you can judge a baby
let me eat it
let me eat it
let me eat that baby
what do you ladies think um i would just
like to pitch a series uh that is
a mashup of moon knight and law order
svu and it's called law and order
special conscious unit and here's the
intro
uh
in the egyptian deity system conscious
defenses are considered especially
heinous
special munich okay yes
you're absolutely right and i'm just
such an idiot the special country okay
but here's here's here's the opening in
the egyptian deity system country-based
defenses are considered especially
heinous in cairo egypt the dedicated
avatars who investigate these vicious
felonies are members of an elite squad
known as the special kanchu munit these
are their
stories then it's a kid who finds a dead
body in the bush
yes
but the dead body is just like the
discarded corpse of an avatar that uh
left behind
technically that's
[Laughter]
unfenced cliff didn't think he would you
would do that
didn't he i'm like he died he probably
died for a good reason the shortest
episode
like
cairo's a popular city
their architecture isn't you know deadly
but that it is it's
deadly
that guys
hazard right you can't put a railing on
every cliff
every cliff can't have yes you can
where there's gonna be dudes knife
fighting nearby maybe um that's knife
you never heard of that about that in
cairo knight fighting cliff
this is
[Laughter]
that was your theory right it's the
special
conscious moon it
no i just wanted to say that but you go
with yourself you sure are okay
i wanted to make sure i didn't like cut
you off
okay so yeah so here's what i think i
don't think the iniad
is it init or any ad because sometimes i
just i honestly don't say like illidan
i mean we're all egyptians so we should
know better right just kidding we're not
egyptian at all
i'm sorry i walk like an egyptian
um
i'm the shape keep going with it
no let's talk about this right now
honestly um uh so
what i think is ineod is not corrupt i
think that they were in a rush and so
they wanted to believe the quickest
thing the easiest thing because they
wanted to get back to the overvoid
and
play a human game that they learned
about
that they are currently in the middle of
and they're playing dodgeball and so
they wanted to get back to their dodge
ball game and overvoy and they're like
yeah yeah okay he said he's unwell he's
closed
nobody call matt murdock this is it this
is done we're going back to the overvoid
we want to finish like they enter their
avatars like out of breath like all
right guys let's give it a try okay
because we gotta get the dodgeball game
going oh all right can't you hope i
really well you missed this dodgeball
game bro
the gods are too lazy to play dodge
balls to play dodgeball themselves so
they force their avatars to play
dodgeball for them
that would be awesome
he wouldn't be
the last one picked in a suit no i ain't
got time for that
oh man i know
i would love if like if during like when
it wasn't being used as a council room
if that room was just like a dodgeball
court
that would just press a button it turns
upside down until like a basketball
oh my god but no i love that you
mentioned the overvoid because like in
case people don't know the overvoid is
the celestial heliopolis of the egyptian
gods like the other dimensional plane
where all the gods live so yeah and they
do meleapolis
the celestial heliopolis it's the other
word for the overvoid it's not as cool
yeah that sounds like the warehouse
where they manufacture heelys
welcome to the heliopolis
everyone's just gliding through willy
wonka instead of instead of like coming
out and doing the somersault he just
does like a sick like ollie on his
heelies
honestly even more impressive than the
somersault let's be real
absolutely
i've already agreed okay
but okay they just wanted to get back to
just doing all right because like
honestly that makes a lot of sense
considering they just abandoned humanity
and they're just like chilling and like
mark just says the word opulence in that
episode like you're killing the
occupants of the overwatch
so humanity abandoned them
oh this is true they abandoned humanity
but
in response to humanity abandoning them
so is it really the god's fault do you
think like what do you guys think do you
think the gods are to blame for leaving
humanity because humanity left them it's
like if i'm not thought of a warship
what's the point of existing and i'm
gonna the controls with brett like it
would be like
i'm sure he is i'm gonna just start
track episode for that
oh my god the hand of god or the hand of
judge
yeah it was like the greek god one
yeah the great god one that's my that's
my favorite episode i have a poster of
that one i'm like right where is it oh
my god the next generation is over there
but t-o-s
original series oh yeah it's the
original series it's a very funny
episode also a really uh sexually
aggressive episode uh
well you know star trek has its moments
yeah the original series sorry we're
going off topic uh we can talk about the
original series any day okay i i agree
though it they are it's just the it's
the same with like well
i feel like it does mimic the eternals
kind of where it's like we were there
from the beginning to help them but then
once they found their own way there is
no like we can't get in we can't meddle
in their affairs we can act right and so
i think it's just like and that is also
god behavior of just like we can't
meddle in life's time like if we do then
all hell breaks loose so i think it's
just them being like they're fine
without us they're fine like arthur
harrow's not scary he's not gonna
release ammet and they just don't
believe that one human can release that
like
crocodile god but yeah honestly my
theory is just that like
like contra to them is like that really
annoying guy who's like in your class or
like in your office or wherever you are
uh and you're just always like oh god
i think greg is here again [ __ ]
i hate that guy and then they're all
like who's gonna deal with greg's
[ __ ] request this time and they're
like not me not [ __ ] me dude and then
they're like oh come on we got it we
gotta
we we all just have to meet with him we
just have to listen and so then like
greg comes in and he's like hey i have a
very reasonable request i'm greg and
everyone's like oh
he's an idiot no okay oh god he has the
worst ideas
parks and rec was really okay uh
it was it was jerry the big guy or was
jerry billy eichner jerry was like the
guy
oh okay i think
billy eigener uh i think he puts himself
into [ __ ] too much he's the person in
your office that's forcing you to come
to the freaking baby show their baby
shower like it's like i i i conscious
the worst khanshu is truly probably the
worst of the group and they're like
why do we gotta even bring them here
honestly i would love it
we're the gods of like hell and [ __ ] we
don't need the god of the goddamn i'm
the god of love and music and you're the
god
humanity didn't even land on the moon
stanley kubrick faked it okay why does
he matter
they probably make jokes behind his back
too like khan chew on out of here like
con i don't know i'm trying to think of
some other one
that escalated
hey
i'm assuming that he's like in my friend
group where i just cuss them out a lot
uh
in this episode
though oh he petty for sure and i i do
find it interesting how harrow mentioned
that kanchu was was jealous i wonder
what he meant by that like it was like
his his his pursuit of ahmed is rooted
in jealousy so like i wonder why he
would perceive kanchu as a jealous type
like who is he going after like is he
going after hator like is there i was
gonna say probably because doesn't have
a following country doesn't have a
following can't you like one of the
biggest takeaways from this episode for
me well wait what like there is like the
cult of conscious in the comics so like
i don't know if he in the comics but not
in the series and that's where i'm like
i think the biggest takeaway in this
series was in this episode specifically
too was how easy and how the gods worked
with their avatars it was like cohesive
and consent and then the with mark and
stephen and konshu it's a disaster so i
was like there is a reason why it's
harder to reach konshu and mark and
steven than it is to reach everybody
else and that's why i was like we need
to keep in mind that the avatars talk to
their god they're like hey what do you
want me to relay because i can relay the
message and it's like forcing stephen
and mark out of where they are for
konshu so that's why i was like it's
easier to follow these other gods
because they're not as aggressive as
conscious so they're avatars per se so
that's why i think he's like jealousy
and it's like yeah you don't have a
following
oh god the following is that even a god
sorry keep going
that was
deeper what's a king to a god what's a
god to a king
something other yeah it's a god to a
damn king baby
what i was thinking of when i heard that
uh mt i'm sure i'm sure you recall this
from the old church days but
when i was in church they used to say
like our god is a jealous god which
meant that he wanted you to not worship
anyone outside of him and that and like
that was like a thing that was said
about god in terms of like
thou shalt not have false idols and
stuff like that so i wonder if when
harrow said that what he meant by that
was like conscious a jealous god in the
sense that he wants mark and stephen to
be totally committed to him follow
everything he says obey his every word
obey his will and like jessica said it's
like trying to put a dress on a cat when
he's trying to get stephen to cooperate
let me tell you that's hard as hell let
me tell you right now
oh you can try i try it every day and it
never works out
jessica
i look at the last time you did this i
said come
[Laughter]
but no i i really love all of these
ideas wait let me throw something a wild
curveball at you because like in the
iniad in um in both the uh marvel and
real life iniad there is a god named set
and he's the god of hate yeah
yeah and like in egyptian mythology set
murders osiris to try to usurp the
throne so do you think that we could be
looking at a scenario here where this
god of chaos is secretly osiris
isn't it and like it's like pulling
things behind the strings i don't know i
just i was reading up a mythology lesson
i was like um
isn't set related to osiris i thought
that was osiris's kid i know osiris had
a child
with anubis wife that a lot of people be
having other babies you know yeah this
is like
that's just a wild theory that i had i
barely like remember the names of my own
cousin's kids so i don't know all these
god's kids yeah he's the brother of any
of them
he's the brother to osiris he's the
brother to osiris in in egyptian
mythology so but you know marvel still
tried to stay as close as possible to
the actual religion um i feel like yes
but osiris's
uh avatar is a little too
s
not stupid but like a little too
like simple
simple yeah
you know it seems like if you were gonna
be the agent of chaos wouldn't you
still not be asking arthur like he's
okay so let's think okay uh film 101.
he's walking behind arthur harrow he's
not walking in front of arthur harrow so
he clearly has no he's a sub to like
arthur harrow he's like asking arthur
harrow like you were right like i'm with
you i follow you
someone that's not even a god it's just
a simple human so i'm like if you're the
agent of chaos and
clearly the avatar to the god of the
underworld why are you so
little to this human man this mortal man
so that's why i'm like i think he would
be much more than what we're seeing if
he was actually the agent of chaos he
would be like i own a room not i follow
a human
he'd be all zany he'd be chaotic he'd be
doing i'd want him to be
yeah i want him to be
a lunatic you know i just wanted
i wanted to be a clown you know i i
would imagine like a local chaos
i am chaos he takes off his pants and
runs
runs through the pyramid of giza
those are the outtakes we're waiting for
them
did you guys see stephen colbert's tweet
from yesterday where he was yeah what
was it
he was like we're three episodes into
moon night and i have yet to see anyone
moon anyone and
so what if hear me out
he moons someone and then runs through
egypt runs through the pyramid uh
he unites uh mark with his butt his bare
butt
puts his foot on his shoulder and then
sprints through the pyramid
one butt cheek on each shoulder chaos
itself the other guns are like
don't mind him don't mind him
he doesn't like pants
but no as always i love all of your
theories you guys are all very smart and
fun cookies and i love talking to you
but i'm give jessica fifteen thousand
rogue points because she made some
really great points like honestly it
could be just like
kanchu was just acting up and the iniad
is just like trying to do its job and
the india does have a really great
relationship with their avatars like
it's really really apparent and with
especially with hatora and and um her
avatar like they're just in sync there
so like yeah i just feel like the idiad
though there could be some slight
corruption the osiris not the most kind
of sketchy dude to me but i just feel
like you know for the most part they're
probably just doing their doing their
job um so if i win this rogue theory
today i will rip this in half on screen
oh my god is that what's gonna happen no
you can't no please you can't tell me
that because i'm destructive and i will
throw the game i will throw i will throw
the game just to see it happen just yeah
okay let's throw the game
the moon god is actually the sun god and
the moon god is actually four
yeah it's just my theory is that
everyone is dead just like in the
just
sixth
bruce willis
hey i i would not i would not take it
put it past the series to have a huge
twist like that that would be pretty
nuts marxists dead people that's
literally what's happening
this is true this is very true he does
see dead people and jackals which is
jackals see your doctor if that happens
to you uh but no i'm gonna give you
ladies 13 000 rogue points as well for
your theories because they're
amazing as well but before we continue
we're going to talk about that
incredible celestial light show up next
but first be sure to head over to new
rockstarsmerch.com to check out our
awesome new moon night inspired merch
including our latest obsession shirt
tomb of the night god inspired by the
artwork on the series and there's also
merch available that features some of
your other favorite titles like loki the
batman peacemaker which i'm wearing
right now it's one of my favorite shirts
and more it's a great way to support the
channel and all the work that we do so
check out all the awesome merch that we
got at
newrockstarsmerch.com we also want to
thank amc shutter for sponsoring rogue
theory we love scary movies here at new
rockstars and when we're in the mood for
a thriller or something supernatural we
turn to shudder where every week they
premiere a new horror movie or series
with shutter you can stream supernatural
thriller and horror movies and tv shows
across all your favorite devices shutter
streaming library has just about
everything from original movies like
super host the boy behind the door and
pg psycho gore man to hit series like
creep show by executive producer greg
nichtero of the walking dead if you're a
fan of old classics or looking for the
next classic you're going to love
shutters collection from around the
world they've got favorites like
halloween and the texas chainsaw
massacre and must see new releases like
vhs 94 and hellbender and to get ready
for doctor strange the multiverse of
madness we've been watching sam raimi's
evil dead trilogy so we don't miss any
of those easter eggs and uh it's very
scary i don't recommend it if you have a
very sensitive sword like mine so stream
all of this and more from shutters ever
growing library ad free for just 5.99 a
month shutter has everything
supernatural thriller and horror i can't
get enough of it and you're going to
love it too and right now you can stream
your first 30 days of shutter for free
f-r-e-e-99
just forget i said 99 just free go to
shutter.com and use code rogue that is s
h u d d e r dot com code rogue stream
free for your first 30 days by going to
shutter.com code rogue and hey it's time
to dig yourself out of that winter
hibernation spring is here and it's time
to get sprung with bluetooth thanks to
bluetooth for sponsoring this video
bluechu is a unique online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis but in chewable
tablets and at a fraction of the cost
take them anywhere day or night and you
can even plan ahead or be ready whenever
an opportunity arises you know you never
know the process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com consult one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days not weeks not
months days it's all done online so no
visits to the doctor's office no awkward
conversations and no waiting in line at
the pharmacy luchu's tablets are made in
the usa and prepared and shipped direct
to your door in a discreet package no
one's gonna know there's nothing sexier
than confidence and blue chew can help
give you confidence where it counts
down there so if you can benefit for
some extra confidence when it's time to
perform blue chew can help you chew and
we've also got a special deal for our
listeners try blue chew free when you
use our promo code rogue at checkout
just pay five dollars at shipping that's
bluechew.com
promo code rogue to receive your first
month for free and visit bluetooth.com
for more details and important safety
information and we thank bluechu for
sponsoring this podcast and hey in 2022
you can wear sweatpants anywhere you
please i'm wearing sweatpants right now
true story that doesn't mean you don't
want to look stylish in them and stance
apparel is here to help not just socks
anymore stance is bringing color comfort
and creativity from toe to head with the
launch of their all new active apparel
line what started off as a radical
reinvention of your sock drawer is now
expanding to your entire wardrobe check
out stance's super soft line of
sweatpants and joggers shirts hoodies
hats and more now available in a full
range of fits prints fabric and fun
embrace a life of superior comfort and
creative expression with everyday active
apparel that truly is stitched different
we are big fans of stance socks here at
new rockstars they're incredibly
comfortable and the patterns and designs
are always super cool and it's always
cool when you can have a little wu-tang
logo or jack skellington poking out of
the bottom of your paint leg because you
know both jack skellington and rutan
clan are not people that you should be
messing with anytime soon and stance's
philosophy is that you should never have
to sacrifice your own individual style
for the sake of comfort and now you
don't have to so whether you're relaxing
around the house working out at the gym
or running all over town stance now
delivers its signature softness in
creativity and a full line of active
apparel styles from toe to head dance
has got you covered so head on over to
stance.com and get 15 off your first
purchase use promo code rogue at
checkout to apply and enjoy color and
comfort of a life less ordinary which
stance stitched
different all right ladies because
another crazy thing we saw happen twice
in this episode was the apparent
manipulation of the uh good old sky up
top there it i already gave my two cents
on this in an episode breakdown and
people really let me hear how they did
not agree but that's okay
twitter this morning was rough my man
twitter was quite interesting indeed
um but hey
some people don't understand how time
dilation
works in respect to gravity that's so
it's totally fine but some people don't
understand that mt's a genius
i wouldn't say genius i'm just a really
weird person that thinks about science
too much but i want to hear your takes
on the second topic for today did konchu
really move the moon and stars because
we see contra uses godly powers to cause
a solar eclipse and move the alignment
of the stars of the night sky back a few
thousand years and it seemed like
everyone could see this like we saw
people just watching that like oh my god
what's going on some guy was like whoa
something's going
around so did can't you actually move
those heavenly bodies and was it all or
like was it all delusion and what
effects might this have had on the
entire planet what do you guys think
i just thought about like how romantic
it would be to be like conscious partner
because he could just move the he can
move the moon and stars for you you can
move them yeah it's the honestly the
best move that's the best thing to do
what's that old movie called i forget
what it's called where he's like bruce
oh my god
i'm gonna throw a lesson around it and
pull it on down for your sweetheart
i don't think i watched any movie in
that time
mighty he he pulls the moon in i think
or was it does he he does yeah he pulls
the moon in for jennifer aniston and
then he causes the tides to tidal wave
japan or some [ __ ] like that yeah okay
so i guess that's my question this is a
hard topic the second one because i have
no
i have no astronomy
uh
brain unless we're talking like being a
capricorn um that is all i have uh
that's all i have to offer so
i i don't know how that yeah without
wear caps
capricorn yay
tauruses are our number one friends
which is probably why hey
angelica what are you
angelica what are you you're shaming
yourself so watch you be a sagittarius
or a scorpio what are you are you a
scorpio
get out of here
by the way just real quick my uh my
boyfriend just heard me doing that
god-awful uh you want me to pull down
the moon for you she impression from the
other room and he just texted me and he
goes babe the movie's called it's a
wonderful life
sorry going back going back so it's a
hard topic i don't know astronomy and i
i but it's like
i forgot where i was going at first do
conscious really move the moon stars oh
well oh how does it affect
the earth okay so which is maybe mt or
someone else would know this better than
i would
moving
the sun and stars would ruin everything
salmon move based off of just the
gravitational pull so it's just like up
every salmon alive and i'm concerned
about that
it's the rivers it's the salmon it's my
periods so i just don't
know
i'm experienced
um
so werewolves think about those poor
guys they're permanently
confused yeah they were just like going
like this
like the whole time
so does it did he revert it back
this is the part that's confusing so did
he revert it back before he disappeared
or are we actually shifted that like 2
000 years or did he just make the night
sky look like what it did 2000 years and
everyone on earth saw it happen so
they're like oh witches are back yeah
like was it like a planetarium showing
or yeah yeah yeah was it just destroy
the galaxy like which i think that's the
question
you ladies that's what that's the
question with that being said the only
thing i could see that they would be
pulling with this with is like
it would be too much on the show to
alter everything because kanchu changed
the moon and stars right i think it
would be way too much to give this man
enough power that it because this would
ripple through the entire mcu like of we
go back 2000 years randomly one day so i
think it is like a planetarium show
but if it isn't
there is a universe off earth it's it's
like off earth it's like a space time
it's it's a weird concept in the comics
where like people are writing freaking
like dragonflies and like mark is just
no power no powerful mark he's just a
normal human so i could see them going
to that universe to go try to save
konchu because i feel like kanshu though
he's in this stone his being is
somewhere else whether it is where the
gods rest or it's just on this separate
plane of existence where no one really
is so i think he could be trying to get
back to there with the 2000 years being
like changed but it's like that is so
much to pull from and that is so much to
change in this short series so that's
why i'm like i still don't see my theory
being true
i guess it's rogue theory so it doesn't
need to be true but like yes rock
staring is going wrong
it's and it's also just like the
implications of like okay so if he
really like turned back time so he
turned back time to a point where like
all of the infinity stones were yeah
and like in the galaxy and it's like god
dammit you couldn't have given you could
have given hawkeye a heads up that he
could just go save natasha real quick
you couldn't have done that you piece of
[ __ ] you [ __ ] why
i don't care about that human i only
care about arthur hair
i just want this guy's life okay i don't
want to help anyone else
so that's where i'm like confused
because and the implications
no keep going i'm like the implications
just must be like
horrible because he did it before and
they hated it so it's like there must be
something that affects
it could be oh so it could be
potentially if we did make them work
together amit he could be like i gotta
change the star so we can find it but it
really releases anime
like it gives one that one small period
window where amit could get out um
honestly like that
at the end of that episode
we do know at the end of that episode
that arthur whispers the country like
hey yeah um my victory's because of you
so like
good looks buddy um so like maybe that's
what he meant he's like hey thanks good
looks on returning back time now i can
finally do what i needed to do and you
big
you big stupid that would follow the
comic book i can't remember which one
wrote this one but the one where am i i
always talk about this one where am it
was the therapist in this like weird
illusion hellscape right working for
consciousness i think that was jessica
meyer's run on moonlight definitely is
it lemire are those lemire i don't know
lemir le meyer
uh i love you one of my friends
[Music]
[Laughter]
it could work it could work because then
he's also like tell mark to come save me
and it's tightening up the loose ends or
rewarding him and being like hey you
helped me do this so now you can do you
can be the moon knight for me and amit's
future or i can just kill you because
you are the only person that knows like
everything that has gone down
um so that could potentially still
happen but there's mine uh i can't i
claim it
[Laughter]
oh god yeah okay i dig it
so i know i'm coming off of a dodgeball
god
game theory but i i'm gonna bring a
little bit of of
at least my knowledge of these egyptian
gods into here and then also my
knowledge of science into this
so damn
we about to get hit with some smarts
ladies
so konshu is the moon god right right
uh-huh only has jurisdiction over the
moon um there is a different egyptian
god that has jurisdiction like he's a
cop
there we go bringing it back around but
um so conscious only has jurisdiction
over the moon right and then there's a
separate egyptian god that has
like rain over the sky
i think
during that scene conscious said i
remember that konshu doesn't
go i have temporal powers where i can
just change back time easily he's going
off of his memory so i think it is an
illusion and also if he was actually
changing back time
instantaneously in that moment we have
to keep in mind that there is
like a speed of light so it would take
what up to
maybe i don't know 100 000 plus years to
even see the light emitting from those
stars if they've actually shifted
so
that's my my science that i just
injected into this
um and why i don't think that konshu has
control over time okay interesting and
the gods just didn't like it because
they didn't want all of the humans to
see
this
huge celestial
godlike event because they gave up on
humanity humanity gave up on them so
they just don't want to
you know ruffle the feathers of humanity
this is true
i love wondering i love when people put
science and mythology and like together
because that's essentially in my opinion
what the mcu is it's just a bunch of
science mixed with a bunch of um fiction
and also religion and mythology that may
or may not be fiction depending on what
you like um but anyway
that was a good answer and now i did it
jessica's never gonna be able to cut
open her thingy no i'm cutting it open
because i'm winning this year
all those moon changes my werewolf's
coming up
but yes i am going to give wait i have a
theory i have yes i'm so sorry
let me tell you okay so here's my theory
my theory is that kanchu had a tweet
that went viral and then somebody
contacted him and they were like yo bro
beneath your tweet could you advertise
my galaxy lights
vibrated
and so then he took the galaxy lights
that he got from
his sponsored post on twitter after he
went viral and then he set up the galaxy
lights and he was like i'm just gonna
[ __ ] with steve
let's just go
check this [ __ ] out check this [ __ ] out
[ __ ] with steve tonight it's going to
be hilarious boys
concho does like to mess with steve this
stands up he does like to bully steve
it's very sad and he needs to stop
that's true it's very exactly hidden
he's a sweet boy i love him stupid
stupid pigeon don't you have someone
don't have a car to poop on can't you
jesus christ
and he flies away
but no i really do like these theories
um but again i do love me when
people mesh science and gods together
like science and weird like fiction [ __ ]
so i'm gonna give
angelica 10 000 points
each and then i'm gonna give both of you
ladies seven thousand points each
because your theories were also very
good um but i still want to see that
thing explode jessica that sounds weird
but that's i don't know why i said that
that way um but yes hopefully you'll
still destroy that
but we have a rogue question next but
first we have a word from bespoke post
because this spring revamp your daily
routine with bespoke post and their new
seasonal lineup of must-have box of
awesome collections bespoke partners
with small businesses in emerging brands
to bring you the most unique goods every
month we've got a little treasure trove
of cool gear in the new rockstars office
from bespoke post some great clothes and
cooking gear no matter what you've got
going on this season box of awesome has
got you covered from camping gear
essentials to cookout must-haves like
hot sauces and barbecue rubs box of
awesome has collections for every part
of your life a couple of their new boxes
look great for outdoor excursions like
the weekender and gadget boxes to get
started take a quiz at box of
awesome.com your answers will help them
pick the right box of awesome for you
and they release new boxes every month
across a ton of different categories and
each box is valued at around 70 dollars
but you only pay a fraction of that
price and plus each box of awesome and
plus with each box of awesome you're
supporting small businesses which is
always great it's free to sign up and
you can skip a month or cancel anytime
so get 20 off your first monthly box
when you sign up at box of awesome dot
com and enter the code rogue at checkout
that's box of awesome dot com
for 20 off your first box box of
awesome.com code rogue all right ladies
it's time for the real question during a
press tour for the lost city sandra
bullock supported the meme of daniel
radcliffe playing wolverine she said you
know just he asked him why not just just
put daniel radcliffe the boy who lived
as the wolverine the man who will never
die so pitch me
why daniel radcliffe should be the
wolverine or if you don't think you
should then give me your rogue is
casting for the wolverine well i'm on
don't everybody say eddie murphy at once
sandra sandra supported right
yeah yeah okay
i'm team sandra because who better to
replace a jacked man than a rad cliff
both solid objects that's true it's very
scary i really enjoyed it
that'll stay with you for the rest of
your life now yes that's the last thing
i'm going to say on my deathbed like
why can't you have a radcliffe
cliff
the cliff drinking a monster energy
it's totally red skating so when you
jump off like a rad cliff you just die
so that's what happened in konshu we saw
that
i'll take it
honestly that's really good
very accurate okay so i think that if
sandra bullock is casting daniel
radcliffe and she's she's the one
responsible for him becoming wolverine i
think that it's only fair to also cast
her so i would like to see a remake
slash reboot of the blind side only this
time sandra bullock's is helping a young
wolverine become the man that she knows
he can be inside
and
and and that's that's what i'm going
with i'm going with sand it's and it's
going to be called the sharp side
because
you know i dig it
the sharp side with sandra bullock
wow that would be hilarious because uh
honestly logan just needs a family at
the end of the day that's what he wanted
the family and the blind side's all
about family
white people taking credit for things
mostly a cigar but also family but if
you have a cigar he'll take that mostly
um
but no i do love that that'd be
hilarious i would love like honestly snl
get on that that's hilarious but what
about you jess what you got those are
two really good ones so i gotta come
from left field um i guess
gotta say that i'm not team sandra
bullock technically uh i love sandra
bullock don't get me wrong sandy b's my
girl but if it means to be on her team
to put daniel radcliff i'm gonna say i'm
not on her team
and i like this blind sideway
uh i think we should also switch it up
and make uh wolverine black but i think
wolverine should specifically be macey
gray
and i think
i think it should be macy's only casting
because i just want and then she comes
in she goes like the pain lets you know
you're still alive
and um
nothing
nothing is
more
nothing
nothing can convey the true pain
that what we're going through
then macy's
[Music]
sorry i'm not making fun of her i love
macy gray no it's i love her so much
that i had to perfect that
voice that was the perfect
you mean wait you don't mean ginger
explains it all nope never mind ginger
explains it all right
i never liked that show but like the
theme song i love that show
that's told by ginger
i'm sorry the animation was always so
weird to me i was like
they're so good their noses are too big
i don't like it so it's ours
we're black
i shouldn't discriminate
he was so hot when he came back with
those braces off and then everyone
wanted to date him and then everybody
wanted to date him everyone the evil
girl wanted to date him are you one of
those
that one of you were people guys i
forget what what the the lorax
themselves
i don't know
it's like i'd buy like a kid from the
lorax or the grinch or something like a
a weird like
i don't know sexually
we can talk about our weird cartoon
crushes
all day yeah
i had a lot i had some cartoon questions
as a kid let me tell you because i was
like i don't have that
horsepower
so
there's a video out there that shows you
all of my cartoon crushes i ranked them
this was back in maguire so do you have
a horse from spirit in there or no i
don't know no because that's just a
horse angelica it is not it's not even
closed or walking on two feet it's a
normal horse just animated it's got
human eyebrows okay
you're like it's eyes are human what
is that skin walker okay that's the
secret lore
we went super rogue but i can't not give
it to
a
me
oh make it sorry
sexy horse but yeah but no i have to
give it the rope question points to uh
macy gray logan because i really i need
to see that if someone wants to edit a
uh a logan poster as with macy gray i
would love that um wait a lot i'm going
to give jessica um 100 000 points making
jessica our winner for today's rogue
theory
destroy it
kill it
oh my god it's gonna happen a box cutter
this is surgery oh my god is your
computer okay
oh my god is everything okay rip it oh
no it flew out of me it flew completely
at me [ __ ] wow
that is it for this episode of broke
theory thank you so much to our guest
jessica clemens whitney van laningham
and angelica trey go follow them
wherever they are on social media and
support them
in whatever that they do they're all
amazing people support our channel by
checking out all of our awesome merch
over at new rockstarsmerch.com and if
you have some rogue theories of your own
please share them on our discord server
so if you're 18 years old and older you
can click the link in the description
box to join the discord and follow me on
masterchain if you wanna see me tweet
some weird [ __ ] and wild theories to
follow new rockstars on all our social
platforms thank you guys so much for
watching we love you so so so much and
we'll see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
you